all right thank you and welcome tonight
to hannity one year ago tonight
president biden assured this country
every american that if they get
vaccinated and they get their booster
they're not going to get covert you
won't get it now the double vac stubble
boosted president biden has just tested
positive for covert 19. i guess so much
for joe biden and dr fauci science now
of course we do very sincerely wish the
79 year old commander-in-chief a very
quick recovery this is not a good
disease i've seen the worst of it we
wish him the best coming up dr ronnie
jackson dr nicole sapphire they will
join us with analysis the great one mark
levin is here tonight but first we begin
with the january 6th committee their big
dramatic prime time grand finale
playing out on capitol hill
uh soon the latest obsessive partisan
anti-trump smear will come to a pathetic
end at least for now they'll probably
try a few more hearings before it's all
said and done
unsurprisingly they did not establish a
criminal case or reveal new damning
evidence against president trump as they
had promised that they would a perfect
example of people over promising not
delivering kind of like the trump russia
collusion hoax remember adam schiff said
oh we we've got all the evidence and
we're proving there was real collusion
the only one that was caught on tape
colluding with a russian prankster was
adam schiff uh what is the nature of the
the compromising materials uh
compromising the material the picture of
the naked trump negative
did vladimir see them but of course
naked pics is a truck remember that one
that was adam schiff well here's the
what the committee purposely admitted
they never bothered to inform the
american people we won't do a total
rehash tonight they didn't attempt to
interview speaker pelosi she's the
person in charge of security at the
capitol chuck schumer the d.c mayor
mayor bowser who preemptively said she
didn't want to guard or the capitol
police chief who himself at first
didn't want the guard but then after a
new assessment came in in terms of
security uh reports he was begging for
the national guard for days he should
have been brought in we should have
listened to him why so we can make sure
this never happens again it's really
that simple they only interviewed the
house sergeant-at-arms behind closed
doors they will not release the full
transcript to every everyone i think
they should be transparent and release
all the transcripts remember these were
the very key people who were ultimately
in charge of security in and around the
capital they were all off limits
according to the chairman benny thompson
now instead the committee brought in in
some cases hearsay witnesses but only
evidence that fit what we said from the
beginning was their predetermined
outcome in order as always to bash smear
slander besmirch donald trump yet again
of course the committee didn't attempt
to corroborate some of these hearsay
allegations with first-hand accounts or
hard evidence i wish they would the
country does have a right to know for
example uh hearsay uh testimony was
given that donald trump tried to
commandeer the beast as they called the
limousine the president is in as a
hearsay witness claimed or not is it
true or not the secret service according
to the press reports disputes the
testimony why not call them in why not
get signed affidavits under oath for
example did cassidy hutchinson
write in her own handwriting as she
testified to a note to mark meadows or
did the president's attorney write it
they both claim to have written the same
note pretty simple to ascertain bring in
a handwriting expert see which person's
handwriting it is instead the committee
you know they ended up playing a lot of
sliced and diced videos i think they
should release them all edit it together
to make donald trump look as bad as
possible they never played the part of
the president's speech when he told
supporters many of you now will
peacefully and patriotically
march to the capitol so your voices will
be heard they didn't play that part of
the speech they never made one mention
of president trump's meetings in the
days leading up to january 6 which we
have discussed in detail before no need
to rehash it all but there are questions
about why mayor bowser wasn't called
nancy pelosi wasn't called chuck schumer
we had a testimony from some people that
was saying
his office had been given a serious
threat assessment in the days leading up
to the sixth
and again what responsibility did they
have to secure the capital take a look
at your screen a few days before the
rally mayor bowser even sent a
preemptive letter rejecting national
guard assistance at the capitol
was there any threat assessment to back
that up why did she do that why didn't
they listen to the capitol police chief
after a new assessment came out a couple
of days leading up to the sixth
he was pleading for the national guard
or is this just blame donald trump
nobody else has any blame any
responsibility in this so the kangaroo
court going on right now never tried to
get answers to really
important questions why are they
important
they're important because we need to
protect our institutions they're
important because we need to protect our
elected officials you know committees
like this need to be bipartisan for a
reason so this way we can learn from
mistakes in the past and protect people
in the future but if your goal is
political if your goal is to smear one
particular party or one particular
person in this case donald trump one
more time you're not going to get the
answers that will solve the problems
that led up to this that's why
republicans were not allowed to have a
say on who could join the committee in
fact every single
member of the committee was a devout
trump hater who already voted to impeach
donald trump how credible is that but
we're supposed to accept that this is
some kind of nonpartisan very important
very historic hearing that deserves to
be televised in full night after night
day after day after day when it's really
just a cheap selectively edited
political ad again release all the
transcripts release the videotapes and
let me be clear
because i said this on january 6th in
real time on my radio show i said it
that night on this tv program
we must secure the capital
we've got to protect our institutions
we've got to protect every elected
official anybody that works in
government and frankly we should be
protecting every town and every city in
this country we need law and order which
is why we should also have a committee
on the 574 riots in the summer of 2020.
we'll get to that in a second we need a
better perimeter around the capital you
know these are things that would have
come out of a bipartisan committee
i would build fences i would build walls
i would use cement barricades you need a
perimeter and by the way for any big
event
going on any marching at the capitol you
need national guard support moving
forward so that something like january 6
never happens again
elected officials
and institutions must always be
protected riots are never okay this riot
the summer of 2020 574 riots none of
it's okay it's not okay at the capitol
building it's not okay in kenosha
wisconsin it's not okay burning down
police precincts in minneapolis or
attacking courthouses or places of
business in portland uh there was no
such thing as a summer of love jazz chop
autonomous zone that was safe we know
people that died in that zone but
democrats seem to want to only pick and
choose which riots they approve on based
on whether they can politicize it that's
why there's absolutely no committee
looking into the summer of 2020 rioting
now remember one fake news cnn
reporter referred to it look at the
background look what it says here mostly
peaceful protests after a police
shooting
the city is ablaze behind the reporter
fiery but peaceful that's one way to put
it mostly peaceful i don't think so
this was a nation
wide wave of arson of looting of mayhem
dozens of americans were dead hundreds
of businesses burned to the ground
billions of property damage
thousands of police officers pelted with
rocks and bottles and molotov cocktails
and worse
thousands injured and you know where's
the investigation into this not only did
kamala harris not condemn these riots
but she selectively then promoted a bail
fund to get violent agitators out of
jail in fact she even praised their
efforts told everyone you beware you
take note they're not going to stop they
shouldn't stop we're not going to stop
really now she's vice president um what
was she supporting take a look
they're not no stop they're not gonna
stop and that's they're not this is a
movement i'm telling you they're not
gonna stop and and everyone beware
because they're not gonna stop it is
gonna they're not gonna stop before
election day in november and they're not
gonna stop after election day and that
should be everyone should take note of
that on both levels that this isn't
they're not gonna let up and they should
not and we should not
okay fair question or not where's the
committee investigating her support her
comments of the riots the insurrection
in the summer of 2020. sadly kamala is
not the only democrat who has called for
political violence take a look for
yourself
you cannot be civil with a political
party that wants to
destroy
what you stand for what you care about
but i like to debate this gentleman and
i said no i said if we were in high
school i'd take him behind the gym and
beat the hell out of them you got to be
ready to take a punch
you got to be ready to throw a punch
[Music]
[Applause]
i want to tell you gorsuch i want to
tell you kavanaugh you have released the
whirlwind and you will pay the price
get up in the face of some congress
people it does you any good running away
from donald trump i think you need to go
back and
punch him in the face but michelle says
that you know when they go low
they go low we kick them
they go low we kick them now chuck
schumer directly threatening gorsuch
kavanaugh on the steps of the u.s
supreme court you won't know what hit
you you will pay the price wow would a
reasonable person uh
tell you that schumer's threat was
worse than so many other statements
encouraging like in the case of donald
trump to peacefully patriotically march
to the capitol so your voices are heard
recently a man armed with a gun and a
knife showed up at justice kavanaugh's
front door with plans to assassinate him
there's no congressional hearing into
chuck schumer and think about it chuck
schumer called for justices who are
appointed as a co-equal branch of
government for life to quote pay the
price you won't know what hit you you
know why we have laws on the books 18
usc 1507 that prevent people from
intimidating and harassing justice's
court officers jurists uh in their
residences uh or at their place of work
and yet nothing nobody talks about uh
stopping the protesting in these
neighborhoods where these supreme court
justices live there are no crocodile
tears from adam kinziger no monotone
lectures from liz cheney no theatric
from fang fang's boyfriend or the
congenital liar uh adam schiff
ultimately the american people see this
for what it is a one-sided political
smear that does nothing to improve our
lives even security at the capitol i
would set up a perimeter keep the
capital safe in the end they're doing a
huge disservice to our country everyone
who genuinely rejects all violence and
all rioting they are doing a disservice
to the country by not looking into the
summer of 2020 preventing that from ever
happening again protecting police
officers from being pelted with bricks
bottles rocks molotov cocktails
protecting businesses from being burned
to the ground police precincts being
burned to the ground they're you know
these are all things we can do to
protect
safety and security of every american so
they can pursue happiness hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else